handy bellman what's up Daniel Dwyer
fallout 4 is pretty great game and we've
been capturing footage for it all week
and you've been doing so using some
fancy cheats which you can access via
the development console tell me about
them well who knew all you have to do is
press the tilde on the English version
the game you get you get a console just
like a lot of a bethesda games that's
add the button underneath escape for
those who don't yeah yeah so here we go
if you're on the PC and you want God
mode just type in TGM that's like TGM
your god mode god mode you got unlimited
ammo in god mode you got unlimited
action points in god mode and you don't
take damage oh wow what do you think TGM
stands for totally god mode okay if it
wasn't before it is now and one of the
benefits of this is oh hello plant what
you can do is then you can go in and
you're gonna set your jump hype so
here's the console command set GS space
F jump height min with those capitals
where you see them capitals are
important and we're gonna set it to 500
which I think his pit boys I don't know
what the scale is well it's okay all
right we're in let's do it now if I had
it not said god mode I probably died
when I came back to boom can you jump to
the top of red rocket oh hell yeah
engines have a red rocket here suddenly
you're playing crackdown yeah crazy it's
another one you can use in conjunction
with this is um you want to set your run
speed okay yeah it's this is gonna look
really funny is it gonna crash no my
jump oh alright can't load this fad now
we're on a beast PC haha yeah this is
like a tri SLI machine so yeah so much
oh wow you're gonna jump straight it I
think I went off the map okay I'm
loading okay you're good um they're
having quite optimized fallout 4 for a
Benny Hill mode oh my god go here's how
you play the game okay there there the
little did I just put the music or
itself oh oh first-person beau we didn't
try that yet here we go now we're
playing Mirror's Edge 2 there we are
there's a diamond city do you think you
can park or your ass in there hell yeah
there let's go Wow I'm a jump height
isn't quite such a trick-or-treater oh
yeah
so press up is it to go yet previous
inputs yeah that's a nice little trick
oh where we at 500 now or a thousand yep
let's see if there's a ceiling no oh
we're in Oh we load it in
I wonder what's gonna put us this
compose in the air oh I just puts me
alright alright settle your eyes down
somewhere
alright let's go in the middle here show
me how to level up so here's a cool one
uh and one that's easy I use this so we
could look at some stuff for guides and
stuff player set level I did a hundred
yeah just and I was wondering if I would
get all the perks and you do they do not
support leveling the player down okay
interesting but if you want to level up
its player dot set level space and then
and then the number and that is 100 the
top level let's see if I go to 111 yeah
what like the vaults likable oh yeah
there we go and you know XP just comes
rolling in baby
oh yeah and every time you level up you
get a perk so there's no top level
alright tell me how to spawn things on
anything this is where it gets a little
tricky little more complicated a little
bit more complicated the base level a
command is really easy just place at me
but then you got a no ID in like a
hexadecimal form of every item you want
to place in your eyes for NPCs you can
look them up on the wiki okay I'm like
fallout 4 wicked icon just has the
number the hexadecimal code there yeah
so let's say we want to spawn a
deathclaw in diamond city okay great a d
thing for that is for a standard def
cloth now there's all sorts of variable
variations but the standard one is FF 0
0 1 5 a 9 I don't know if that worked
yep sure I hear it sounded like it
worked hahaha so here's a house employs
a deathclaw done zinnia Wow don't have
to worry about since anymore guys
deathclaw in your front yard
yeah so now there's a way to set how big
you have stuff fits in it oh so let's
see if dogmeat needs a little help okay
yeah he's chewing away to death blob
ever maybe if his jaws are a bit bigger
he could take bigger chunks out of it
yeah so this is an easy one just set the
scale uh and then it's a number from one
to ten so let's go bake or just have to
look at him I think was I haven't tried
this yet okay we're doing it no
apparently that didn't work maybe you
have to click on him in the console then
do it yeah I'll do it
that's a oh my god yo make the death
call ten as well uh yeah why not okay so
you click on the death claw and then
just press up it'll do it
yep look up where'd it go oh my god it's
Godzilla all right boom boom boom go
hello ah
Oh mines like Mars Attacks now Heidi we
can hang out with you whoa whoa oh he
just flew into the air its semen see
this is the type of thing that happens
when you've cheap before lash it gets
crazy it gets crazy look up again
where's the gun oh he's flat oh whoa he
died I think that's talks of him writing
now Evan I wonder if you get hella scrap
not if I loot him like 6000 yeah
I love a xpz I tell me about the room
Andy no room tell me about the room so
there's this awesome room that if you
want to see every item in the game and
just like what we won't show any
spoilers stuff but you can probably
stumble onto some named items and other
stuff in the boxes that will certainly
be a little spoiler your inbox also
there's every pot like there's tons of
power armor set up so if you don't want
to see what the xo1 power armor looks
like but you know if you played fallout
2 you know what it looks like so yeah
COC COC q a spell
q a smoke got it and it basically just
fast traveller to this thing presumably
put here for testing purposes by the
game makers themselves it's kind of like
this weird world well like aerial so it
has I think it just has like every
texture and stuff in the game everything
you'll find all the crafting stations so
you can mess around with stuff test
terminal there's just like all the
weapons around rooms up that you want
and then all these power armors over
here to mess around way yeah just
hanging around
it's excellent so that's it but then the
problem becomes how do you get out of
here right take self out of here if it's
in Gavin tree yeah yeah yeah but how to
get out of here you can't fast travel so
you're kind of stuck here so you got to
know this command COC again and you just
got a know a specific place to go okay
an easy one is Red Rocket e xt okay and
then it just takes you the red rocket
you can use that COC to go like anywhere
if you know the name of the tile
yeah D ballon thank you so much for
showing us I guess the essential Chi Chi
to know for I for yeah there's plenty
more look him up we will I would want to
do another video bedroom on gamespot
calm
you